wednesday pft pm special guest today
texas defensive end jj watt that's
coming up momentarily before that though
the biggest news of the day and it's
been a very newsy week this one kind of
came out of the blue
brett tesler who represents 49ers
running back for he mostly who had that
game for the ages in the nfc
championship
against the packers mostert had been
trying to get
a new contract from the 49ers he's due
to make 2.75 million
this year hasn't gotten what he wanted
and now he wants
to be traded this isn't necessarily the
best climate
for any player to be trying to finagle a
trade with all the uncertainty
arising from the pandemic you'll hear a
lot about that from jj watt coming up in
a few minutes but
the 49ers just have this revolving door
that they've worked to perfection and
whoever they plug in
seems to get it done they still have
jared mckinnon who's been with the team
for two years
trying to get to 100 they believe that
he still can be a very effective player
in that offense if he's healthy
they traded matt breida they've got
plenty of guys
i don't think they're gonna let
themselves be held hostage at the
running back position by one guy who
wants to be paid a lot of money
because they recognize maybe unlike any
other team
the value of having multiple running
backs
who know the system it's about the
blocking it's about the play design
and there are a lot of guys out there we
talk about this all the time with
running backs the supply
of capable running backs far outweighs
the demand and that's very instructive
as it relates to the situation
with dalvin cook in minnesota
same offensive philosophy same approach
and they've got alexander madison who
could step in if cook decides to hold
out
mostert wants out in san francisco if
they do trade him or if he holds out
they'll be fine with the other guys that
they have
and that's just kind of the way it is
and most may not like it
but the 49ers unlike any other team
understand
that running backs i don't want to quite
say they're fungible
but they're pretty close to it as anyone
with any position on offense or defense
would be in an nfl system
i think the 49ers feel that way about
the runnings back because we've seen
them get it done with a bunch of
different guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports